dan to this house pilot the
[ __ ] Bombardier coming to rest
at you
there you go [ __ ] it's the
Lord's Day [ __ ] it's cloudy it's
sunny it's rainy a tornado an earthquake
I don't give a [ __ ]
we're sparking today it's the Lord's Day
[ __ ] haven't seen you in a few
days
I missed you as usual you know I can't
live without you [ __ ] but I
can't come on e every day because then
what would we have we got nothing was
that the same boring fat [ __ ] every day
with the same [ __ ] thing so we take a
few days off you know it's nice to see
you it's nice to go on an adventure and
find different reefers so I could bring
them back to the periscope of life and
share them with you today we got [ __ ]
dead star and we got [ __ ] venom you
understand me we're going deep into the
murky [ __ ] waters of the
underworld the fights last night I only
watched the last one Tyron Woodley
that's my man Stefan Thompson I don't
know what they were waiting for I don't
know if they're waiting for a [ __ ] DJ
or what the [ __ ] was going on but now we
got the answer to all our [ __ ]
questions who's gonna fight who when why
but you know what that's not my the most
important thing so that's just one of
the many things the most important thing
today is about you [ __ ] and how
you gonna make it work this week I
already been up an hour writing my goals
putting a couple paragraphs in the book
all right I was gonna work out today I'm
gonna do a little work I left the house
no jujitsu because I got a podcast that
one which you guys will see later on I'm
on I'm interviewing the [ __ ]
undercover cop that busted the [ __ ]
serial killer The Iceman how to Jersey
in my [ __ ] old neighborhood with the
prong gaze and York Motel it's gonna be
[ __ ] tremendous but joy what's with
the [ __ ] cheddar Charlie understand
Chuchu we're gone deep play this reefer
is [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] yo Romero
smoked when he need [ __ ] now Chris
Weidman in the head you understand the
first time I smoked I was walking around
all day lifting my knees like a [ __ ]
Nazi and heat but anyway we're here
we're queer
we got a podcast at 6 o'clock tonight we
got a podcast Wednesday I'm out with red
band tonight at the improv next week
[ __ ] my boobies in Baltimore
I'm gonna see my main man [ __ ]
John Rallo
don't forget EBI tonight you know the
[ __ ] deal dawg co-op listen if you
stop moving you'll stop feeling the
[ __ ] breeze you always gotta keep
moving Dawg because if we don't move
you'll [ __ ] settle into the floor and
then what do you guys got nothing you
you're the same as all these other
[ __ ] mutts together [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we're always making [ __ ] moves
you should be playing an ally with me
see snoop I don't wanna be I don't see
nobody it's me I guess the [ __ ] world
you understand me the same way it's you
against the [ __ ] world I'm
still until he kills I ain't gonna lie
to you I love smoking marijuana with you
people
it makes my [ __ ] Lord's Day a lot
better if more people smoke dope before
they went to church church will be
packed I got Heidi that day I want the
[ __ ] church on Wednesday for Ash
Wednesday was [ __ ] tremendous I cried
I giggled I hate to cook head and drink
the wine I don't want the [ __ ] flu
you know I'm saying 90 people drinking
out of one chalice somebody's gonna get
sick oh you got a shot a bad breath in
your mouth you can't get rid of it for
two [ __ ] weeks let's try this [ __ ]
venom cuz it's how we Road [ __ ] we
ain't got time to dick around today I'm
saying we're taking this [ __ ] to the
hoop give it take somebody's [ __ ]
trouble every day in my [ __ ] world
I'm also giving up [ __ ] edibles for
Lent you know why because they're not
hitting me like they're supposed to be
hitting me so I'm gonna give it a
six-week [ __ ] hiatus that's how I
roll just to show you people we could
stop stop start do whatever the [ __ ] we
want we control our [ __ ] destiny and
well what am I gonna do I'm gonna miss
the best part so what I'm a smoke weed
no edibles still [ __ ] Easter Sunday
and then I'm gonna eat like 3,000
milligrams on the show and have to call
the ambulance the whole [ __ ] I gotta
get my heart beat again [ __ ] so
edibles are done for Lent will still
happen at the office I don't mean I gave
a passage from life to [ __ ] THC
crystal explosive Jim Sam which is
giving up edibles for life I gotta make
a point in the stem sometimes
you teach by [ __ ] examples
oh my god this is the [ __ ] that made
[ __ ] Pontius Pilate right on Jesus
anyway like I said you got a big week is
the biggest week of your life don't
worry about me [ __ ] this is the
biggest week of your [ __ ] like what
are you gonna do how you gonna make it
happen
how you gonna [ __ ] make somebody suck
a dick and tap how the [ __ ] you gonna do
that that's what you should be thinking
about I'm bored today right out your
[ __ ] goals do you twenty two push-ups
it's over you keep doing that every
[ __ ] day and things will happen you
walk around you go out you [ __ ]
engage people you can't not get a job
you can't not do what you wanna do in
your life if you don't [ __ ] engage
people you don't engage people and your
[ __ ] computer you [ __ ] you
engage him or hold 200 you understand
you ever see me wearing sunglasses
never you can't find a picture uncle
Joey wearing [ __ ] sunglasses I was
raised in a [ __ ] seventies
[ __ ]
why look in your eyes and you look at my
eyes [ __ ] the [ __ ] diet
7-eleven is so me too [ __ ] he's gonna
suck me nicest lighter ices lighters
don't turn off you saw me like a Gentile
[ __ ] light
have I told you people I love smoking
reefer with you
all right there anyway it's a cloudy
gloomy day but that don't mean that my
insides are gloomy I'm led by heart and
nutsacks that's it that's what controls
my [ __ ] mood
my heart and my [ __ ] at nutsack and
they're in a great mood everyday it's a
Tod bump into one of these confused
Gentiles it tried to ruin my day like
Milo your Napoli's but they can suck my
dick like Milo you Napoli's because
uncle Joey always [ __ ] prevails and I
suggest that you mother [ __ ] prevail
today's that day what are you gonna do
today the [ __ ] make them suck your
dick today you tell me I'm not a [ __ ]
mind reader here if I was a mind Li that
wouldn't be here talking to you I'd be
at the track betting [ __ ] daily
doubles anyway I'm gonna side I gotta
write a little bit more on my [ __ ]
book i Melissa - [ __ ] Lennox get it
give me back my bullets so I put the
[ __ ] fear of death and me understand
me give me back my bullets and don't
even think about listening for the last
out not today don't listen to [ __ ]
last one it's gonna down to like this it
gets you to [ __ ] [ __ ] warmed up you
gonna murder somebody on Monday they're
gonna blame that on uncle Joey
the I got I said miss alright [ __ ]
next to you what are you crazy anyway I
love you [ __ ] with all my heart
I am what I am
alright and you are with you are then
make believe you something else imma
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] my kid and crack
jokes part-time but anyway I love you
[ __ ] till the end till I'm worth
this out and then Spanish like I tell
you [ __ ] all yet they didn't
get my mutton our ping the holy boy if
it didn't come I much of a pig now
alright anybody [ __ ] you tamil Joey set
your momma Mel a pinga [ __ ]
and that's it Church tonight six o'clock
see you then have a phenomenal day may
your families be [ __ ] strong American
strong
and don't forget to go out there this
week and fifier if you listen if you
don't do it for you just do it for your
[ __ ] dad before you [ __ ] me
punches the ticket you want to see him
go down as you as a [ __ ] champion you
understand me
so get out there don't take no [ __ ] from
nobody don't believe the hype they're
all [ __ ] wrong um I'm a liberal I'm a
conservative I'm made of balls and steel
[ __ ] New Jersey style and I suggest you
do the same
stay black uncle Joey loves you see you
tonight six o'clock on the [ __ ]
podcast alright keep smoking I'll be
watching the old day